hello everyone and welcome to the evan
carmichael show here on the lifestyle
talk radio network i am your host and
your friend in all things
entrepreneurship evan carmichael i want
to talk to you about your business today
and i want to help i've helped almost 20
million entrepreneurs with their
companies and i know it's hard i know
you're trying to do everything yourself
i know you have a lot of questions and
so if you want to call in you have a
question the number today is
seven 1-888-454-3378 and i'm also gonna
be checking on tweets so if you wanna
tweet me at uh at evan carmichael we'll
be checking in and answering questions
today i'm really excited to be here this
is my first time here on the lifestyle
talk radio network i'm from toronto i
flew into new york so we're coming to
you live from new york city right now i
flew in last night got to meet some
local entrepreneurs
got to spend the night salsa dancing
away
in the in the east village
and now we're coming to you live from
studio flying back out tonight and i
want to get to your questions i want to
start today
by talking about how we value ourselves
as entrepreneurs and too many of us
undervalue the products and services
that we're putting out there we're not
charging enough
and as a result
we don't make the money that we deserve
to make we don't have as much fun with
our business we're not working with
ideal clients like we should be
and you gotta raise your prices and
stand firm in your belief that you
deserve those prices
now if you're just getting started up
fine you know you take on new clients
you undercut your prices because you're
just looking for some experience
but if you're really good at what you do
and you should be
as an entrepreneur you should be master
class your goal should be to be the best
in the world of what you do
and if that's you you deserve to charge
what you're worth
when you do that you'll feel better
about yourself you'll be making more
money you can have a greater impact
you're working with more ideal clients
it makes all the difference in the world
too many of us undervalue our prices
we're working crazy hours sometimes when
you work out the numbers you're working
for minimum wage
and so you've got to increase the value
of your service and feel confident that
you can charge more for it
i have a friend of mine named jason
who is a life coach in toronto
and he's really good at what he does
he runs a company called rise online
and he changes people's lives
even from one conversation with him
you're going to come out a different
person
and i went to go meet him recently we
had an avocado milk chick at one of my
favorite local spots
and
i said jason what's going on how are you
doing how's business what's happening
and he told me that he was struggling
i said what jason you're struggling
how are you struggling you're killing it
people love you you look on your website
there's awesome testimonials of all the
great things you've done for people how
are you
struggling
and as it turns out
he's just been targeting the wrong
people
he's helping a lot of people up but they
can't afford his services
and so he's undercutting his prices
because he wants to get the deal
and that's not the way to build a
thriving successful business and a lot
of us fall into that trap
you've got to go after people who value
you for what you're doing who want
somebody who's master class who's
providing amazing products and services
that are helping them and you've got to
believe in what you're selling
now jason has switched his model around
and he's going after companies
who can afford him he's going after
individuals from the financial sector
and lawyers and investment bankers
people who can't afford his services
and he's increased his prices five times
and it's making all the difference in
the world for his business
by going after these ideal clients and
people who respect his time and value
his time
he's able to make more money
he's able to have more fun with his
business he's able to feel like he's not
just struggling to get along
and it's the same business he's doing
the same thing that he's good at
he's just increasing his prices
and going after better clients
and i think that's a trap that a lot of
entrepreneurs fall into you know for
whatever reason
we undervalue ourselves
we know we're really good at what we do
we know we can help people but when it
comes time
to closing the deal
we knock ourselves down on price
and that's not the way to build a
thriving long-term successful amazing
business
you have to know the value of what
you're putting out there
and then have the confidence to stand
behind that pricing
that can evolve over time when i first
started
working with brands i work with a lot of
brands for trying to target
entrepreneurs
somebody asked me to write a blog post
for their website and they said they
paid me 500 bucks to do it
i said 500 bucks you're gonna pay me to
write you know some couple hundred words
i get a link back to my website let's do
it and as it turns out
i added so much value to their website
that more people started coming to me
they started seeing the impact that i
could have and helping them and i
realized i should be charging more for
this you know i'm not just a writer on
their site i'm driving people to their
website they're getting a lot of value
from it
and so i increased my prices now that
same service that was 500
is 2500
and i'm confident that pricing because i
know that i can help those companies
and that's where it comes from
so if you're just starting your business
or you're already in business you're
looking to get to the next step
examine your prices
understand that
you're providing a lot of great value
and you deserve to be paid what you're
worth
and you've got to start charging
accordingly i want to get to your calls
again the number 1 888
454-3378 or you can tweet me at
evancarmichael
we have our first caller on the line
carl
carl where are you from and how can i
help
sure i'm from uh charlotte north
carolina
welcome to the show well thank you i
just listened to what you said and now
i'm getting depressed
[Laughter]
sorry to hear that
i'm just obviously teasing but
i i've been a victim of that myself i've
made myself a victim of undercutting my
prices when
i should be making a whole heck of a lot
more to relieve a whole heck of a lot
more stress you know so you just got me
thinking i forgot i was actually on the
on the phone so i appreciate that i just
learned something i haven't talked to
you yet
um
my question is i own a few music
construction stores in this city um i've
been doing it for about 25 years i've
been in my my own business for
13 years
we set the standard in the city in terms
of that type of business
when i first started the business
a lot of people there wasn't a lot of
music construction stores but now
they're really almost every other block
you know fast forward 13 years later
so there's a lot more competition and
that's one of the reasons why i lowered
my prices but i'm going to go ahead and
work on that but my main question is i
have three locations
and the problem i have when i start one
location i then i you know i can't be at
the other location and then what happens
things start to fall apart do you have
any advice of that in terms of
um management and
some different tools i can use who's on
your team carl well i'm hopefully
hopefully you are but i have some
management companies as well
uh a management uh in each uh in each
location i'm running it but when it
seems like when i'm not there what
happens is there's like a little mutant
goes on and you know what this is common
and the challenge here is you can't do
everything yourself
and to be able to grow you've got to
have people under you who you can trust
to do it and if they're not doing their
job
i'm sorry to say but but that's on you
carl
you know you've got to do a good job in
both recruiting people at the start
letting them know what's expected of
them
and then following up to make sure
things are happening
and people
like to know that there's structure and
there's someone who's caring for them
and and
you know is invested in their future and
so you want to be that inspirational
leader you know you should be able to
not have to go to any of the locations
and focus on the high growth part of you
know where you want to take this
business next
yeah i i thank you for that i agree um i
would like to continue to either
franchise or license this out we have a
great thing but this is the second time
in my life so i'm doing something wrong
that i have had a mutiny where i was
back in the corner in other words you
accept this offer from us or we're just
all going to walk out of your business
anyway and
not only have you lost a sale you also
lost your business at least one of them
that's happened twice so far so i it i
know it's something that i'm doing wrong
here and
i'm just trying to figure it out you
know so i continue moving forward
yeah it does sound like there's
something wrong with you and it's great
that you've uh figured that out already
uh i would really spend time and sit
down with your key management and ask
them what's wrong and be honest let them
know that you know you think when when
you're not there
uh that things are falling apart and
what they would do to fix it and and let
them know that you're open to criticism
um you know we've got to just quickly
move on but for those of you who are
listening who have similar problems if
you want to grow a franchising type of
business you got to show that you can
make it work on a local level right you
got to make one store work and three
stores work that's what's going to be
able to allow you to build a huge
infrastructure and build up from there
thanks to the call call car we're going
to keep going we are talking
entrepreneurship i want to help you with
your business i know you can't do
everything yourself you have a question
i want to hear from you you can call in
again the number was 1-888-454-3378
and you can also ping me on twitter i'm
at evan carmichael i see a lot of
questions already coming in so i'm
excited to be able to get to them as
quickly as we can but i promise first
that i'd share with you my number one
tip for entrepreneurs and this is the
most important thing that you have to do
when you're starting the business
you have to follow your passion you've
got to do something
that you love to do because in other
words otherwise you're going to fail
if you look at any successful
entrepreneur at the core
is a strong passion for what they do and
money comes as a byproduct of it if
you're helping people
and you love what you're doing you're
going to make money
but if money is your only goal
you're going to quit as soon as it gets
hard
you're not going to make it
starting a business is going to be one
of the hardest things you ever do in
your life there's going to be lots of
ups and downs and unless you absolutely
love what you're doing
you're not going to have the fortitude
to keep going
a lot of entrepreneurs come to me and
say evan i want to make a lot of money
what business should i start and that's
the exact wrong approach to take
it doesn't matter what business you
start do you have a passion for it or
not if you have a deep love strong
passion for it and you're helping people
you will make money
that should be your starting question
instead of how do i go and make a lot of
money the guys who do that who just go
and try to make money they don't and
they lose money they lose their
investment they lose their time they
lose their energy and i don't want that
for you
i want to make sure that you're starting
the business around that strong passion
because all the other rules in business
won't help you
nothing else will help you
if you're not following this one core
principles following your passion
i hope you guys will implement that i've
got a caller on the line we've got susie
susie where are you from how can i help
i'm from minnesota and my question to
you evan is about branding okay
i own a boutique and you know i am just
trying to
do my branding and differentiate myself
from other boutiques and how to stand
out and
did you have any advice on branding and
how to go about doing that
sure what kind of boutique do you have
why did you start it
sure it's women's clothing and
accessories and
i
love clothes and i love helping style
people and i've had buyers in my family
so i've always been in purchasing and i
decided to take the leap of faith and
open up my own boutique
that's great what's it called
it's called suzetro suzetro so you get
you get your free uh plug here on the
radio suzetro in minnesota
so what does that name mean where did it
come from
sure it's a nickname that i got in high
school suzetra
and
etra means to be so it's kind of like
to be
in you know in fashion in in france and
my first location was off of a location
called 50th and france and so it just
kind of seemed to fit
cool and so what's your branding now
you've got the name do you have a
tagline that you use yeah i've been
using the eiffel tower
and just kind of um plugging on the you
know one of a kind because we are kind
of known for one of a kind at reasonable
price points
and so that's really what i've been
using
um but again you know just kind of
trying to
you know how do you go about that for
you know marketing and you know getting
to your customers and those kinds of
things
do you tell your story at all how you
got started where the name came from
your picture
um
not i mean not so much like other than
you know like the website and different
you know articles that have been in the
paper and things like that
um i've done it that way but as far as
like reaching every individual customer
um
you know how to how do i do that you
know how do you get it into you know
like a one sentence
you know getting to every customer yeah
you know what i want to hear from you
susie is i want to hear your passion for
the business so you're talking about the
company
and it's great i know what you do but i
haven't heard
why you love doing what you do what
makes you different so i said you know
how do you send out
and it makes sense logically but you
haven't hit me on an emotional level
and you could tie that into your brain
so i want to know why you're passionate
about this business
can you tell me can you tell me on the
line right now what makes you excited
about this company
absolutely i mean i love clothes i love
helping people find what fits them
women are so hard on themselves and i
really try to help them it doesn't
matter what size it is i really like
helping them
you know feel good about themselves and
dressing for their different body types
and
you know lots of times an older customer
doesn't want to look too young or you
know they think they're too fat or this
or that but
all that doesn't really matter it's
really you know how you feel about
yourself and how you think you look in
something and so i really try to work
with the customers and find the right
you know body type and the clothes that
fit them
and
just really trying to make them feel
good is really what my passion really is
i like that a lot more that's really
great so now you got to get that story
and crunch it down
okay so i know you know you're i'm
putting you on the spot i'm kind of
being a little mean but i'm just trying
to help
uh if you can get that you know five
sentences down to one
and it should be something if you're
talking about your branding this is how
you're representing yourself to the
world you should read you know what what
you're putting out there and get
inspired yourself and say yes this is
why i started this business
and so if you're talking about
women being so hard on themselves and
you make them feel good you help them
find something that can
lift their day
you want to incorporate that message
so on your website
on your brochures i would definitely
tell your story have a picture of
yourself a nice smiling picture because
people like to buy from people
not just a corporate brand
and this applies to your business but
everybody else out there as well
you want to tell your story that's this
is our opportunity to differentiate if
you're going up against the big brands
like you're in a competitive market how
do you stand out you tell your story you
make it personal
and so all of your marketing should also
include this story and the passion you
have for this business and how long
you've been around and what your goals
are and how you feel you're really
helping people that should help drive
everything that you're doing and you're
attaching people to your story and the
passion that you have
before they're going to care about the
x's and o's
and the specifics of you know what you
do that's better
so the way to stand out is through your
story so if you're if you're doing your
branding now i mean you already have
your name
as a part of your company with suzetro
which is great
but i just try to use your story as much
as possible so so refine it get it down
to your elevator pitch all that stuff
that you just said
in five minutes you'll crunch it down
into into one sentence
uh we've got to move on thank you so
much for the call susie and for
everybody else who's having similar
issues you think about how to promote
yourself
the way to stand out
is to use your own store and i'm going
to share a story later on in the session
today
but that's your opportunity to stand out
that's what can help separate you in a
competitive field and you're going to
attract people who are a lot
more of your ideal client
we've got a lot of questions coming in
we're already halfway through the show
this is crazy i'm having a lot of fun
with you guys
before we ended the last segment uh we
were talking to susie was having
problems with her branding we talked
about putting her more of herself into
the business and i i promised you i'd
share a story about a friend of mine
who's lady gaga's personal photographer
so this guy's name is rich who runs a
company called you gotta love
and he shoots celebrity photos he gets
paid to do this it's an awesome job
and uh if you look at his website you
see all these new celebrities who was
brought in it looks like he's on top of
the world
so i meet up with him recently we go
grab a coffee
like rich what's going on
how's business
and he tells me that uh he's getting a
little bored that you know he wants to
grow but
it's kind of flatlining at the moment
like rich what that's crazy you're
working with lady gaga you've got all
these celebrity clients it's growing
you've got a great website what's what's
happening what would you do
if you weren't doing this photography
business
and he said that he wants to spend more
time writing the blog
sharing
his ideas and things that he's learned
about himself
now a quick background on rich he's a
he's an interesting off-the-wall kind of
guy he's he's a lot of fun
one of the nicest people you're gonna
meet but he's a little out there
he's into some weird stuff so
as an example he unschools his kids
so he doesn't homeschool he unschools he
doesn't like using chemicals so he was
looking for a way to replace his
deodorant and so he found that cutting
up lemons and rubbing them on himself
that was the best way to do it so he's
into some funky stuff
and that's what he wanted to share with
the world the stuff that he's learned
and wasn't sure if it would be a
business or not
i said rich you got to bring this into
your business
this should be part of your company this
is part of your branding
it's like really you want me to tell my
story about using lemon as deodorant on
my website i'm going to lose people
like rich
you're going to lose some people
some people are going to read that story
and say this guy's crazy i'm never going
to work with him
but chances are those guys are not going
to be your ideal clients anyway
they're going to be too conservative too
stuck up you're not going to have a
great time working with them they're not
going to be repeat clients they're not
going to refer you business
those guys who say this guy is too crazy
for me
you don't want them as clients anyway
other people
are going to read that and instead of
saying
this guy's crazy they're gonna say this
guy is crazy
i gotta go work with him
and celebrities are funky bunch you know
lady gaga is not a normal person
she's crazy
and that's why she gets along with rich
because he's crazy too
and so you want to inject more of
yourself into your business
because if you've got the lady gagas of
the world
researching
you know five different corporate
photographers who to go with
and all of them have you know the same
kind of boring websites with just
galleries and then there's this one
website
riches where he's sharing his story
sharing all this funky stuff about
himself he's making it personal
people will feel instant connection to
him
and his ideal clients are more likely to
want to hire him
than to work with somebody else
same thing with susie
we go back to her boutique
she helps women feel comfortable about
themselves she talks about how women are
too hard on themselves and the women who
are going through that if she puts that
on her website that she understands how
hard it is
that women put all this pressure on
themselves to look good and find the
right fit if she talks about that and
how she helps people
then the people who are going through
that
they're going to pick her store over
everybody else's
and they're going to spend more money
there they're going to refer business
there and she's going to have a lot more
fun working with those people because
she's attracting ideal clients
to her business
so back to rich
it's the same story
incorporate that in
use those lessons that you've learned to
make it part of your business
for all of us as entrepreneurs at the
very least at the very least if you had
to do one thing
put your face up on your website
put a smiling picture
put a little bit of your story
and that alone is going to help make you
stand out
too many entrepreneurs
hide behind
what they think should be a corporate
professional website
and it's limiting you
you want to inject your personality into
your business it's going to help you
bring in those clients
so at the very least put your your face
your story tell your passionate story
why you got started if you're feeling
more ambitious do a youtube video have
you on camera i know i know what can be
intimidating when you're starting start
a blog show the things you're interested
in
i'll talk about if you go to my facebook
page or twitter i'll talk about what i'm
into besides business like salsa dancing
baseball
my toronto blue jays are on a eight-game
winning streak
and that attracts people to me as well
and i'm bringing more of an ideal client
base into me people feel like they know
me without me having any idea who they
are
so inject yourself into your business
don't make it that you have to have your
business on one side and your personal
stuff on the other side and your hobbies
and your riches bring them together
that's how you can separate and stand
out
i want to get to the phones we've got
callers coming in we've got
joe on the line
joe where are you from and how can i
help
i'm from pine bluff arkansas arkansas
welcome to the program well thank you
glad to be here
i've got a corporation
and uh i've got some investors that are
in arizona and they want to do some
investing with me
and now all the lawyers i talked to in
arkansas tell me that i can't go down
there and take an investment from
i'm a privately held corporation it's
only me and my girlfriend that own it
we're not listed on the stock exchange
or anything
okay
if you're a corporation uh i mean i'm
not as familiar with uh specific u.s
laws i'm actually based in toronto
canada
but when i was in the venture capital
business we helped fund a lot of
different businesses a lot of them were
us and and if you're a corporation
uh there shouldn't be a reason why you
can't get uh get investors from from
outside if you set up a corporation
well that's what i was thinking but
they've all i've asked like five
different ones and i've got five
different answers and it was all well it
all boiled down to no you can't do that
until you come talk to us and we get uh
you know some advanced money from you
i mean that's
what i took it as they just wanted to
get me in there to get the money first
and then say oh well you can go do this
sounds like you might need some new
lawyers there well that's what i was
thinking
now how about your investors did they
have lawyers yeah yeah they uh with one
investor said his lawyer would take care
of everything he'd fly me down there and
do it and all and i said well
that sounds great to me and i'm just
waiting on him to uh
get everything worked out on that end
but uh you know i don't see why i can't
do that i mean
it might be a little one-sided me
working with his lawyer
it is always good to have a trusted
lawyer you know in your back pocket to
review all your contracts right but you
could have his lawyer spend all the time
and money and and hours and building the
contract and just have your lawyer
review it it saves you a lot of cash
right
but having a team and this is part of
what you need to do as you build a
successful business you need you need a
team of professional service advisors
around you so you need a good lawyer you
need a good accountant
you know maybe a good bookkeeper
you got to build this team
you know they're not full time on staff
but when you have problems like this
like you get the wrong investment advice
here it could sync your company right
so you got to have somebody who you can
trust in your back pocket who can review
that contract for you and let you know
it looks pretty good joe but these three
points
you know they're screwing you over on it
right so
i would really spend some time
in your market
get to know some of the lawyers maybe
you can get some referrals from some of
your entrepreneurial friends or look at
the better business bureau and see who
they recommend and interview them
and not the guys who are going to rip
you off and say hey you want an hour of
my time it's going to cost you 400 bucks
right yeah i've heard that a lot
somebody and there are lawyers there are
great lawyers who will meet with you the
first time for free because they want to
get to know your business
that's the kind of lawyer who you want
to work with exactly i just need to find
one
yeah and i mean you make that your goal
you're going to find them yep well that
is my goal i need to find a good one
like you say because all the ones i've
talked to so far have just led me astray
yeah i mean i would still put a lot of
the work on his lawyer let them spend
all the hours and let him rack up the
bills and just have your lawyer do the
work on your side to give you some
advice
joe we've got to move on thank you so
much for the call for those of you who
are who are listening you got to build
up your team
you need to have a lawyer in your back
pocket an account in your back pocket
people who you can talk to for advice
as you build your business it's
essential you don't want to be flying
blind but we are talking all things
entrepreneurship today we're almost at
the end of our show
every entrepreneur multiple times in
their lives think about throwing in the
towel and quitting
we never talk about it we don't share it
but we're thinking it
you can't quit
if you love what you're doing and you're
helping people
you can't quit
you owe it to yourself you owe it to
your customers you owe it to your family
you want your community to keep going
and i know it's tough i know you wake up
some mornings maybe it's a rainy day
outside you had a crappy week
no sales were coming in you just feel
like staying in bed
you got to get out of bed and go to work
and do something to grow your business
today
because if you don't do it nobody else
is going to do it for you
the cavalry is not coming this is on you
to make it happen
you started this business for a reason
think about what you were doing before
you started this business
probably working at a job you hated for
a boss you hated doing work that was
beneath you
well the news flash is
if you don't get out of bed and go to
work and do something a great business
today you're going back to that life
and that should be painful for you
that should make you want to get up and
go do something
try to think of specific experiences
that happen to you
maybe your boss embarrassed you in front
of everybody or maybe it made you do
some work
that was so far beneath what you felt
you should be doing
you want to think about those times and
say to yourself i never want to
experience those things ever again in my
life
your way out is to get your business
going
and to keep going one more day one more
day one more day and even though
the light at the end of the tunnel you
can't see it you're not quite sure how
it's going to work out you've got to
keep going
another tool that i've used that's been
really helpful
is you don't want to live with regrets
and this is one of the most common
things that happened for entrepreneurs
who quit their businesses and then go
get another job
a year later
you're in this crappy job that you hate
again
and you're thinking
i really wish i gave it more
i really wish i gave it my all i really
wish i got up that day and did something
to grow my business
because that's a lifetime of regret
that awaits you
you don't want to have any excuse any
crutch
for saying that you didn't give it your
best when jeff bezos started amazon.com
he was 40 years old he was a vice
president
the youngest vice president ever at his
investment bank company he gave it all
up to go start this book company
online and people said what
you're starting this online book company
are you crazy you're on the fast track
man
you're about to make it big and you're
throwing it all away to start this book
company this is before.com was really
taking off
and he said you know what if i don't do
it i'm going to regret it the rest of my
life
and so he did it and he's had huge
success
you don't want to live with regret
don't give yourself any excuse
for not giving it your best
i want to get to the calls we've got
time for i think one last caller i know
twitter's blowing up we've got lots of
calls coming in one last caller over to
julie julie where are you from and how
can i help
i'm from kansas city and i have a
gluten-free dessert company
and i'm now shipping to six states in
the midwest congrats that yeah
it sounds bigger than we are but uh um
but we have grown enough to be in six
states
and my question today is i'm trying to
decide since i am the cell owner the
main employee you know i do everything
i have a manufacturer
um
that can distribute as well for me but
the problem that i've got is that kind
of exactly what you were just talking
about is that when you get so tired and
worn out of being you know the only one
doing everything
that uh at what point do you bring on a
partner and i'm trying to decide if i
want to bring on a strategic partner
because i do have an option
with a gentleman who knows like brokers
and things across the nation and he can
take you nationwide
but he's not willing to necessarily
invest money
for employees and marketing and things
like that but he can help me get it
nationwide
or do i take on a partner that has some
energy and some money
but uh um doesn't have the inroads to
getting me as big as i would like to go
so i'm kind of at this quandary of what
to do that's a good thing nothing and
just to keep it status quo
as entrepreneurs we're everything from
the ceo down to the janitor when we're
first starting up you know you're doing
everything
and what you want to figure out is what
are you really best at
and surround yourself with the team of
people who can compliment your
weaknesses
so whatever you're really good at in
your business if it's if it's baking
these desserts or whatever it is
that's what you do and you the higher or
partner out the other tasks when you're
bringing on a partner with your business
it's like getting married
believe me i had a partner initially and
it did not work well
you got a date first before you get
married
yes
uh so and that's great you've had that
experience ready because a lot of people
just jump into it and uh it can be a
nightmare and you could lose your
company over the wrong partnership
yes
any partner that you bring in you have
to make them prove it especially if you
already have an existing business you're
not just starting from scratch
you're not nothing hey i just have a
startup idea here you've built something
you should be proud of that so anybody
who's coming in either has to invest or
have to prove themselves to you so this
guy
who wants to take you national let him
prove it oh he has already he grew a 75
million dollar company a food company
let him prove it for you
let him do something
to go out
and start bringing you some sales and
let him earn his equity in the business
and show that you guys can actually work
together because even if it makes sense
from a business point of view sometimes
the personalities don't match or his
values don't match
you know we we uh often see partnerships
through these rose-colored glasses at
the beginning
you got to make sure that it's you know
the right fit
i'm excited for you though julie uh
we've got to move on thank you so much
for the call
for everybody who is looking at a
partnership opportunity make sure that
you test them out don't just give them
your equity
make sure you test them out and you can
work together and you know it's going to
be a good fit long term not just from a
business point of view
that's a great question one that a lot
of entrepreneurs go through to build
your business up you have to go beyond
yourself you can't do everything
yourself forever it's going to limit you
so you need to have the people around
you to help support you
we're done already this is crazy for all
you people on twitter that i missed adi
sola dieter
morgan james lauren i'm sorry we
couldn't get your questions i'm going to
answer you by twitter later i promise
thank you so much everybody for joining
me you can check out my website
evancomic.com follow me on twitter
evancarmichael and i hope to see you
guys soon good luck have a great rest of
the week thanks guys